Queridos amigos, amigas, esta mujer que veis
en pantalla es Maia Sandu , la presidenta
pro-europea de Moldavia, uno de los países
que está viviendo la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania con más tensión.
Y no, no estamos exagerando.
La propia presidenta describe la situación
actual como el momento más peligroso de toda
la historia del país.
Y de hecho, tan sólo una semana después
de que Rusia invadiera Ucrania, Moldavia solicitó
unirse a la Unión Europea.
Un proceso que, por supuesto, no será nada
fácil ni tampoco rápido.
Hablamos de un país que rivaliza con la propia
Ucrania por el título de país más pobre
de Europa y que, además, tiene serios problemas
políticos.
Empezando porque de facto ni siquiera tiene
el control territorial y fronterizo sobre
el conjunto del país.
(“Somos el vecino más frágil de Ucrania,
somos el país más afectado por ella y somos
el país que tiene menos recursos para hacer
frente a la situación y las consecuencias
de la guerra".
Nicu Popescu, Ministro de Asuntos Exteriores
de Moldavia)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué tanta ansiedad de repente?
¿Qué demonios tiene que ver la invasión
rusa de Ucrania con Moldavia?
¿Por qué su presidenta dice que este es
uno de los momentos más peligrosos de toda
su historia?
¿Qué es lo que explica exactamente titulares
como este?
(24 de abril del 2022: “Los funcionarios
estadounidenses y ucranianos sopesan la “alta
posibilidad de que Putin invada Moldavia”.)
Un momento, ¿podría llegar a repetirse en
Moldavia lo que estamos viendo en Ucrania?
¿Puede ser esta la continuación de la guerra?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(UNA DIVISIÓN ALIMENTADA POR RUSIA)
Moldavia fue la segunda república más pequeña
de la Unión Soviética y cuando ésta se
derrumbó y Moldavia declaró su independencia
Rusia respaldó una rebelión separatista
en Transnistria, dando lugar a una especie
de nueva república.
(De la misma forma que el río Dniéper divide
a Ucrania en dos, el Dniéster divide a Moldavia
en dos regiones claramente diferenciadas desde
el punto de vista étnico y lingüístico.
Mientras que al oeste del Dniester Moldavia
está formada por ciudadanos de etnia moldava
rumano-parlantes, en Transnistria domina una
clara mayoría eslava que habla ruso o ucraniano
como lengua principal.)
El caso es que desde que se consumara la ruptura
entre estos dos territorios, tropas rusas,
unos 1.500 efectivos permanecen desplegados
en la República Moldava Pridnestroviana más
conocida como Transnistria, uno de los países
no reconocidos más extravagantes del mundo.
Con unos 500 mil habitantes, aunque se cree
que apenas viven en ella poco más de 200
mil personas, esta estrecha franja de tierra
situada entre Moldavia y Ucrania, está dirigida
por separatistas pro rusos y vive en buena
medida de Rusia.
Moscú le suministra no solo seguridad, sino
también Gas Natural gratuito y complementos
para las pensiones.
En cierta forma pasear por las calles de Tiraspol,
la capital transnistria, supone algo así
como retroceder 40 años en el tiempo para
regresar a una especie de Unión Soviética
con tintes modernizados.
Hablamos de un lugar dónde sus residentes
viven bajo un aluvión de propaganda rusa.
Eso sí, más allá de la hoz y el martillo
que aún mantienen en su bandera, podemos
encontrar muchas diferencias con la extinta
Unión Soviética.
Por ejemplo, desde la década de 1990, la
economía de Transnistria ha sido monopolizada
por una empresa, el Sheriff.
Una compañía que fue cofundada por el ex
agente de la KGB Victor Gushan con ayuda de
varios colaboradores suyos y que hoy posee
de todo, desde la cadena nacional de supermercados
hasta el club de fútbol homónimo de la Liga
de Campeones pasando por los gimnasios, las
empresas de telecomunicaciones, las gasolineras,
el tabaco, el alcohol….
Incluso controla el propio partido gobernante
de Transnistria, conocido como Renovación,
que tiene 29 de los 33 escaños del Consejo
Supremo.
Es decir, para entendernos, Transnistria no
es un país comunista sino más bien un país
al servicio de una camarilla de oligarcas
que lo controlan todo.
Por supuesto, tal y como os podéis imaginar
no existen muchas oportunidades para personas
que no tengan lazos con esta pequeña élite.
Pues bien, el caso es que ahora la guerra
de Ucrania está volviendo a tensar y mucho
la situación.Tras la solicitud de adhesión
de Moldavia a la UE formalizada el pasado
3 de marzo, Transnistria ha vuelto a exigir
el reconocimiento de su plena independencia.
(Luego, el pasado 22 de abril, un general
ruso, Rustam Minnekaev afirmó que el objetivo
de Moscú pasaba por ocupar toda la costa
de Ucrania y abrir una ruta directa con Transnistria,
porque según denunció en Moldavia se oprime
a los rusoparlantes.
Prácticamente la misma acusación que durante
mucho tiempo el Kremlin hizo contra Ucrania.)
Lo que, por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar,
ha hecho que a muchos en Chisinau se les pongan
los pelos de punta.
Para colmo, apenas 3 días después de esta
desafiante declaración, una explosión dañó
en Tiraspol el Ministerio de Seguridad del
Estado y un día después dos explosiones
más destruyeron antenas utilizadas para retransmitir
la radio rusa.
Nadie, absolutamente nadie, reclamó la responsabilidad
sobre estos atentados, lo que ha puesto sobre
la mesa algunas preguntas:
¿Fueron acaso saboteadores ucranianos intentando
dañar objetivos rusos?
¿O fueron en cambio los propios rusos para
justificar algún tipo de operación militar
mediante lo que se conoce como operaciones
de bandera falsa?
Queridos amigos, amigas, Moldavia es uno de
los países más pobres de toda Europa, apenas
tiene un diminuto ejército obsoleto y mal
equipado que ni siquiera cuenta con aviones
de combate y que apenas tiene 6 helicópteros
de transporte . Sus tanques son poco más
que antiguallas que encajarían mejor en un
museo que un campo de batalla y, además,
el país apenas cuenta con 6.000 soldados.
Además, Moldavia nunca ha perseguido incorporarse
a la OTAN.
Y de hecho, desde 1994 el concepto de neutralidad
está recogido en su propia Constitución.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Qué podría estar
buscando Rusia en un país que no puede suponer
ninguna amenaza?
¿Existe realmente el riesgo de que escale
el conflicto?
Pues…
Bien, veámoslo.
(EN LA ENCRUCIJADA)
Exactamente, ¿Con qué objetivo Moscú podría
querer extender el conflicto a este nuevo
país?
Amigos, Rusia tiene un amplio historial a
la hora de recurrir a este tipo de operaciones
de “bandera falsa” y el propio Presidente
Zelensky, dijo alto y claro que las explosiones
eran obra de Moscú.
Y aún más, según la inteligencia militar
ucraniana, en Transnistria se habrían preparado
una enorme cantidad de folletos instando a
los rusos a que se levanten en armas contra
Moldavia o, incluso también, contra la propia
Ucrania.
De hecho una de las primeras cosas que hizo
el ejército ucraniano fue dañar los puentes
que las tropas rusas podrían llegar a utilizar
para apoyar un ataque sobre Odessa desde la
propia Transnistria.
Pensad que a los 1.500 efectivos rusos hay
que sumarles los entre 4.500 y 7.500 soldados
que componen el ejército de Transnistria.
En total entre 6.000 y 9.000 soldados que
Moscú podría utilizar para alcanzar sus
objetivos.
Tanto en Ucrania como en la propia Moldavia.
(Los soldados rusos más el ejército de Transnistria
podrían terminar en Chisinau en una hora",
Alexei Tulbure, analista político y exembajador
moldavo ante las Naciones Unidas.)
Claro que no se trata solo de los rusos.
En el municipio de Cobasna, un pueblo en el
norte de esta región separatista, se encuentra
el depósito de municiones más grande de
Europa del Este.
Podríamos estar hablando de unas 20.000 toneladas
de municiones de la era soviética que llegado
el caso los ucranianos podrían querer neutralizar
o, incluso, intentar apoderarse de ellas.
Para que os hagáis una idea de todo lo que
puede haber allí metido, en el año 2005
la Academia de Ciencias de Moldavia estimó
que una explosión en este almacén sería
comparable a la explosión de la bomba nuclear
sobre Hiroshima en 1945.
Claro que estamos hablando de material muy
antiguo que fue renovado por última vez hace
ya más de 30 años.
Pero aún así la posibilidad está sobre
la mesa…
Y esto es algo que podría contribuir a escalar
el conflicto.
En cualquier caso, evidentemente, lo que más
aterra en Chisinau es que el país pueda terminar
como la propia Ucrania.
(“El futuro de Moldavia depende de si el
ejército ucraniano se mantiene.
Luchan no solo por Ucrania, sino también
por nosotros.
Iulian Groza, analista del Instituto de Políticas
y Reformas Europeas en Moldavia)
A ver, por fortuna hoy una invasión a gran
escala de Moldavia por parte de Rusia parece
algo prácticamente inviable.
El desastre militar al que se han enfrentado
en Ucrania puede haber frenado por completo
esta posibilidad.
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que Moldavia
no tiene de qué preocuparse?
Pues, amigos, amigas, nada más lejos de la
realidad.
Digamos que en este caso Moscú cuenta con
otras armas.
Además, la presidenta Sandu llegó al poder
en 2020 con un mensaje claramente crítico
con Moscú y muy pro-europeo.
Mientras que su contrincante electoral y actual
líder de la oposición es todo lo contrario:
Igor Dodon, líder del Partido Socialista,
es un político pro-ruso y marcadamente antioccidental.
Así pues, ¿Estará el Kremlin pensando en
una operación de cambio de sillones?
¿Cómo podría intentar conseguir este objetivo?
¿A qué amenaza real se enfrenta Moldavia?
Bien vamos a responder de forma concreta a
estas preguntas, pero antes veamos qué es
exactamente lo que podrían querer conseguir
en este pequeño y pobre país del este de
Europa.
Atentos.
(¿CAMINO A LA UNIÓN EUROPEA?)
El día 15 de noviembre del 2020, Maia Sandu
ganó las elecciones ni más ni menos que
con el 58% de los votos.
Entre la diáspora obtuvo ni más ni menos
que el 93% de los apoyos.
Esto supuso la salida del poder de la facción
pro-rusa de la política moldava.
Fue toda una sorpresa para Moscú: Su aliado,
Igor Dodon parecía contar con un enorme poder:
había sometido a prácticamente todas las
instituciones del país y tenía mayoría
en el Parlamento.
Incluso se sospecha, por ser suaves, que utilizó
esta enorme concentración de poder para vigilar
de forma ilegal a sus contrincantes políticos.
Por si fuera poco también recibió un importante
apoyo financiero y político de Moscú.
Pero ni con esas.
Las guerras internas entre los prorrusos y
el creciente descontento popular hicieron
que a finales del 2020 el viejo debate moldavo
entre mirar más a occidente o mirar más
a Rusia se inclinó claramente por mirar a
occidente e intentar la integración en la
Unión Europea.
Eso sí, con todo, la principal promesa de
Sandu fue la lucha contra la corrupción y
los oligarcas sin escrúpulos.
[Un momento, ¿un mensaje pro-europeo y anticorrupción?
Ufff ese coctel es demasiado para la Rusia
de Putín.
Demasiado]
Sea como sea hablamos de una apuesta que se
consolidó en julio del 2021 cuando el partido
Acción y Solidaridad de Maia Sandu obtuvo
una clara mayoría absoluta en las elecciones
parlamentarias.
Y es que amigos, Moldavia es un auténtico
desastre.
No sólo es con Ucrania el país más pobre
de Europa con un PIB per cápita de apenas
4.500 USD, el equivalente a países como Paraguay,
Guatemala o El Salvador, sino que hace treinta
años el país tenía 4,4 millones de habitantes.
Hoy en cambio se calcula que su población
podría ser incluso inferior a los 3 millones
de habitantes.
Es decir, hablamos de un país que no solo
ha experimentado un enorme desastre económico
sino también un gran éxodo de población.
De hecho las remesas son prácticamente la
primera industria del país.
Suponen casi el 16% de toda la economía moldava.
Un buen ejemplo de cómo han funcionado las
cosas en este país, lo tuvimos en el año
2014 cuándo saltó la noticia de un escándalo
bancario que rápidamente pasó a ser conocido
como “el robo del siglo”.
En tres días, aproximadamente mil millones
de dólares fueron robados de tres bancos
moldavos y lavados en el extranjero.
Hablamos del equivalente a una octava parte
de toda la economía nacional.
La operación fue dirigida por el oligarca
más rico del país, Vladimir Plahotniuc,
con el apoyo del propio gobierno.
El caso es que por todos estos motivos, fue
por los que Maia Sandu ganó las elecciones
en 2020 con un objetivo muy claro: modernizar
y limpiar de corrupción al país para ponerno
en dirección a la Unión Europea.
Algo que tal y como os podéis imaginar no
le hace ni pizca de gracia al Kremlin, Y de
hecho, al poco de estrenarse en el cargo la
nueva presidenta comenzaron los problemas
con Moscú.
La pregunta es, ¿qué puede hacer la Rusia
de Vladimir Putin para recuperar su influencia
en Moldavia?
Atentos.
(GOLPE DE MANO)
La pregunta es: ¿Podría Moscú intentar
un golpe de mano para forzar un cambio político
en Moldavia?
Ojo, que esto es algo que podrían conseguir
por varias vías:
Primero, una operación de bandera falsa en
Transnistria podría darle la excusa a Moscú
para desatar una campaña de castigo militar
y económico contra Moldavia:
("Rusia utilizará cualquier influencia que
tenga para garantizar que Moldavia tenga un
gobierno prorruso.
Irán por un cambio de régimen", Diplomático
extranjero en declaraciones a The Economist)
Podrían, por ejemplo, amenazar con atacar
el país con misiles o incluso de tener finalmente
éxito en Ucrania -por difícil que hoy parezca
- intentar cambiar el gobierno por la fuerza.
Esta sería la posibilidad más drástica.
Pero, amigos, también podrían emplear estrategias
de guerra económica.
Rusia podría desatar toda una tormenta económica
sobre Moldavia.
Porque amigos, Rusia tiene la economía Moldavia
cogida de pies y manos.
Y es que veréis, por un lado, el oso Ruso
suministra casi todo el gas del que depende
Moldavia para hacer funcionar su modesta industria
y abastecer la calefacción.
Y podéis creerme si os digo que hablamos
de un país dónde en invierno hace frío.
Y algo parecido ocurre con el petróleo.
Además las principales tuberías pasan por
Transnistria.
Así que la amenaza sería más que factible.
De hecho esto es algo que Moscú ya ha utilizado
para obtener ventajas políticas.
Por ejemplo, en octubre del 2021, Moldavia
se vio obligada a declarar el estado de emergencia
después de que Gazprom redujera los suministros
en un tercio y exigiera que Moldavia pagara
más del doble del precio anterior para mantener
el flujo de gas.
O que aceptara un nuevo tipo de acuerdo:
(“Gazprom ofreció a Moldavia un nuevo acuerdo
de gas a cambio de vínculos más débiles
de la UE Grupo ruso acusado de utilizar la
crisis energética para castigar al nuevo
gobierno prooccidental.
FT)
Si Moldavia aceptaba modificar su acuerdo
de libre comercio con la UE y retrasar la
aplicación de las normas comunitarias, entonces
tendrían gas barato y abundante.
Al final, según parece se quedaron a medio
camino.
Moldavia consiguió gas y Rusia concesiones
políticas.
Pero eso no es todo.
Cerca del 80% de toda la electricidad de Moldavia
es producida por centrales situadas en la
república separatista de Transnistria.
Y la compañía eléctrica que es de propiedad
rusa ha venido aumentado considerablemente
los precios y obligando a Chisinau a negociar
la compra de electricidad por periodos muy
cortos de tiempo.
De esta forma, si un mes no se renueva el
contrato de electricidad o se interrumpe el
suministro de gas, la debacle para Moldavia
podría ser considerable.
Moldavia está intentando superar esta situación
construyendo conexiones eléctricas con Rumania,
pero tardarán años en estar listas.
Los gobiernos pro-rusos no hicieron nada para
reducir la dependencia Moldavia de Moscú.
De hecho, casi a la desesperada el Ministro
de Infraestructuras y Desarrollo Regional
ha apuntado que el país está barajando comprarle
electricidad a Ucrania.
Pero claro, ¿es realista depender de un país
en guerra que está siendo sometido a fuertes
bombarderos?
(“La libertad y la independencia energética
tienen un coste para nosotros, y después
del inicio de la guerra en Ucrania, no tenemos
más remedio que pagar este costo de la independencia".
Andrei Spinu, Ministro de Infraestructuras
y Desarrollo de Moldavia)
Por supuesto la idea de Moscú pasa porque
todos estos problemas terminen desgastando
al gobierno pro-europeo y llevé a los moldavos
a abrazar de nuevo a la Madre Patria Rusia.
Y ojo, porque una evaluación de inteligencia
publicada por Estonia este mismo 2022 apuntó
muy claro a que el Kremlin estaba ya trabajando
activamente para derrocar al actual gobierno
pro-europeo.
Según apuntaba este informe Moscú utilizaría
como armas, precisamente, la dependencia energética,
la influencia de la Iglesia Ortodoxa - con
la que Putin se lleva particularmente bien
- y la propia televisión en ruso.
Y desde luego, la propia presidenta tiene
pocas dudas de que el clima política va precisamente
en esa línea:
(“Las fuerzas políticas rusas en Moldavia
ya han estado hablando de protestas masivas
y han estado pidiendo al gobierno que renuncie
y celebre elecciones parlamentarias anticipadas,
para que puedan culpar [de las dificultades
económicas y los altos precios de la energía]
al gobierno", Maia Sandu, presidenta de Moldavia)
Amigos, amigas, Moldavia atraviesa un tiempo
difícil.
A los incrementos del precio del gas y la
electricidad, se suma el impacto de la guerra.
Unos cien mil ucranianos refugiados se han
asentado en el país, una cantidad enorme
para un país tan pequeño y pobre.
Además cerca del 14% de las exportaciones
moldavas que hubieran alcanzado Ucrania, Bielorrusia
y Rusia se han detenido, la inflación se
ha disparado hasta el 22% por el mayor coste
energético y también por el incremento de
precio de las importaciones al interrumpirse
el tráfico a través del puerto de Odessa.
El principal puerto utilizado por el comercio
moldavo.
Recordad que hablamos de un país sin salida
al mar.
Para colmo las remesas procedentes de los
países en conflicto también se están desplomando.
Y solo Rusia supone más del 10% de todos
los ingresos que Moldavia obtiene por esta
vía.
Es decir, que el Kremlin podría estar tentado
a complicar aún más las cosas con protestas
en las calles de Transnistria, cortes de luz
y gas o, incluso, la amenaza de utilizar acciones
militares.
Ya sabés, supuestamente para proteger a la
población culturalmente rusa.
Quizás la mejor noticia hasta ahora para
Moldavia haya sido precisamente lo mal que
las cosas le están yendo al ejército ruso
en Ucrania.
Pero dicho esto turno para ti: ¿Crees que
finalmente Putin intentará cambiar el gobierno
de Moldavia?
¿Será esta la vía para escalar aún más
el conflicto?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.